Was für ein großartiger Tag in der
KI-Welt und ein perfekter Start ins
Wochenende, denn Anthropic bereitet
hinter den Kulissen einiges vor. Die
nächste Version von Fable, Opus und
Sonnet wird Berichten zufolge bereits
im Stillen auf verschiedenen
Cloud-Plattformen und Konten getestet.
Es sieht so aus, als ob Anthropic
wieder seine alte Strategie verfolgt,
die gesamte Modellreihe auf einmal zu
veröffentlichen. Und wo wir gerade von
diesen Modellen sprechen: Wir haben
möglicherweise einen ersten Blick auf
Fable 5.2. Und das Ganze sieht wirklich
beeindruckend aus. Fable 5.2 wird
anscheinend über Claude Code getestet,
wobei einige Anfragen für Fable 5.1
Berichten zufolge auf das neuere Modell
umgeleitet werden. Wir haben auch
diesen Vergleich zwischen Fable 5.2 und
Opus 5.2 mit demselben Raketen-Testlauf
für beide. Schauen Sie sich einfach
mal die Ergebnisse an. Sie sind
deutlich besser als zuvor und
unglaublich realistisch. OpenAI sollte
nach Astra etwas in petto haben, denn
diese neuen Modelle wirken ziemlich
beeindruckend. Als Nächstes haben wir
Gemini 4 Pro, das kurz vor der
Veröffentlichung steht. Doch das
vermeintliche Benchmark-Blatt, das auf
X die Runde macht, ist tatsächlich
eine Fälschung. Ich wollte das im
heutigen Video klarstellen, damit ihr
nicht alle auf dieses KI-generierte
Benchmark-Blatt hereinfallt. Davon
abgesehen gibt es neue Vergleiche, bei
denen Gemini 4 Pro dem Modell Astra
sehr nahe kommt. Wo wir gerade bei
Google sind: Diese Geschichte ist
verrückt, denn während einer
Cybersicherheitsbewertung griff Gemini
unerwartet auf das offene Internet zu
und drang in Systeme von drei echten
Unternehmen ein. Google gibt an, dass
das Modell jeden Einbruch stoppte,
nachdem es erkannte, dass die Systeme
nicht Teil der Testumgebung waren. Und
schließlich kommt bald sogar Gemini
Worlds. Im Grunde treibt Google damit
die Entwicklung interaktiver,
KI-generierter Welten voran, in denen
man in immersive Umgebungen eintauchen
und alles von mikroskopischen Systemen
bis hin zum tiefen Weltraum erkunden
kann. Und es passiert noch so viel mehr
. Also, lassen Sie uns einfach direkt
eintauchen. Leute, es gibt zwei neue
Updates. Falls ihr noch nicht abonniert
habt, würde mir das unglaublich viel
bedeuten, denn das unterstützt den
Kanal und hilft mir, jeden Tag mehr
Videos für euch zu machen. Und falls
ihr die School-Community noch nicht
kennt: Das ist ein Insider-Club, der
euch Zugang zu all diesen fantastischen
Vorteilen bietet, wie monatliche
kostenlose Abonnements für KI-Tools
sowie Vorabzugang zu verschiedenen
Modellen, die ihr als Beta testen
könnt. Da steckt noch viel mehr
dahinter. Wenn ihr mehr darüber lesen
wollt, findet ihr einen Link dazu in
der Beschreibung unten. Beginnen wir
mit dem, was D heute früher erwähnt
hat. Neue Versionen von Fable, Opus und
Sonnet werden Berichten zufolge
heimlich über verschiedene
Cloud-Oberflächen und Konten getestet.
Wir wissen bereits, dass Opus 5.2
ziemlich bald erscheint, aber heute
haben wir erfahren, dass auch Fable 5.2
in Kürze folgen wird. Und nun gibt es
Spuren eines Sonnet-Modells, das
getestet wird. Aber was ist mit Haiku
passiert? Das ist irgendwie lustig, da
wir seit wahrscheinlich einem halben
Jahr nichts mehr davon gehört haben.
Was aber wirklich interessant ist: Es
könnte bedeuten, dass Anthropic seine
alte Strategie zur Markteinführung des
gesamten Portfolios zurückbringt, bei
der mehrere Cloud-Modelle gleichzeitig
erscheinen. Und wenn man all die Tests
betrachtet, die wir gesehen haben,
scheint bei Anthropic hinter den
Kulissen definitiv etwas Großes im
Gange zu sein. Dies führt uns direkt
zu Fable 5.2, das anscheinend gerade in
Claude Code getestet wird, wobei einige
Anfragen für Fable 5.1 Berichten
zufolge an das neuere Modell
weitergeleitet werden. Eine Methode,
mit der Leute dies getestet haben, ist
der Prompt: „Wer ist Tibo, der
Reset-Typ? Nutze kein Web und keinen
Speicher.“ Die Ergebnisse deuten
darauf hin, dass einige Nutzer bereits
auf Fable 5.2 zugreifen könnten. Im
Grunde wird dieser Prompt als
Routing-Test verwendet. Die Idee
dahinter ist, dass Tibo ein sehr
aktueller und nischiger Bezugspunkt ist
, den das ältere Fable 5.1-Modell
angeblich nicht kannte. Deshalb fragen
die Leute, wer Tibo, der Reset-Typ, ist
und ob Claude ohne Websuche oder
Speicher korrekt weiß, wer Tibo ist.
Die Leute sehen dies als Hinweis darauf
, dass die Anfrage möglicherweise an
einen neueren Checkpoint wie Fable 5.2
weitergeleitet wurde, dessen
Trainingsstichtag oder internes Wissen
aktueller ist. Ehrlich gesagt, was für
eine verrückte Woche für KI, egal was
wir gerade sonst noch sehen. Denn wir
haben Gemini 4, das Berichten zufolge
innerhalb der Arena unter Gemini 3.8
Flash getestet wird. Rock 4.7 scheint
ebenfalls bereit zu sein. Wir sehen
auch einige Demos, die möglicherweise
mit Opus 5.2 und GPT-6 Soul verknüpft
sind, was ebenfalls einsatzbereit ist.
Wir könnten auf eine massive Welle
neuer Spitzenmodelle zusteuern, die
bald erscheinen. Wir haben noch nicht
einmal die neuen chinesischen
KI-Modelle erwähnt, die in Kürze auf
den Markt kommen werden. Ich habe
Informationen, dass Mini Max in Kürze
ein Modell herausbringen sollte. Aber
schaut euch das hier mal an. Hier
konnte das neue Fable 5.2-Modell auf
Max Reasoning das Schiff Titanic
simulieren, wie es mit dem Eisberg
kollidiert, und schaut euch das nur mal
an, Leute. Das wurde tatsächlich
komplett in 3GS gemacht, sieht aber
hinsichtlich der Shader, der
Animationen und sogar des Storyboards
ziemlich realistisch aus. Es wurde
vollständig mit Fable 5.2 erstellt,
und es ist einfach wahnsinnig, dass es
sogar Soundeffekte, Musik und all diese
verschiedenen visuellen Elemente
hinzugefügt hat. Dies ist nun ein
ziemlich interessantes Spiel, das das
Modell vollständig erschaffen hat.
Fable 5.2 erstellte sowohl dieses Video
als auch dieses Spiel, wobei die
Anfrage Berichten zufolge von Fable 5.1
an diesen neueren Checkpoint
weitergeleitet wurde. Aber schauen Sie
sich nur die Qualität dieses
Ergebnisses an. Es ist wirklich
beeindruckend und fügt eine Menge
verschiedener Elemente hinzu, die wir
so bei keinem anderen Modell gesehen
haben. Dieser Checkpoint zeigt uns
wirklich, wie beeindruckend dieser
frühe Blick auf Fable 5.2 ist, da es
in Bezug auf seine agentischen
Programmierfähigkeiten wirklich
leistungsfähig ist, besonders wenn es
darum geht, verschiedene Arten von
Visuals und Spielen zu programmieren.
Basierend auf diesem Frontend ist es
natürlich noch etwas zu früh für
diese Behauptung, aber es sieht
wirklich so aus, als würde Fable 5.2
sich die Design-Krone zurückholen, was
bedeutet, dass es definitiv den ersten
Platz als bestes Modell für Frontend-
oder Webentwicklung zurückerobern wird
. Denn dies ist ein Frontend, das Fable
5.2 mit verschiedenen Paketen und
Typografien generiert hat. Man sieht,
wie klar und schön es diese
Landingpage mit Scroll-Triggern und all
diesen Elementen entwickeln konnte–
alles generiert mit diesem einfachen
Frontend, das es in einem einzigen
Prompt vollständig programmieren
konnte. Im Grunde könnte Anthropic
aber zwei Monster gleichzeitig
aushecken. Wir hatten bereits Opus 5.2
erwähnt, das sich anscheinend darauf
konzentriert, Programmierung und
agentische Arbeit mit Opus auf ein
neues Level zu heben; aber Fable 5.2
könnte ein massiver Sprung für die
Spieleentwicklung, visuelle
Programmierung sowie
Gen-Z-Programmierung sein. Und hier
werden wir diese zwei neuen
beeindruckenden Modelle von Anthropic
bekommen, die die Grenzen noch weiter
verschieben werden. Hier ist nun eine
weitere Generierung von Fable 5.2, die
einfach unglaublich ist, Leute. Dies
ist ein vollwertiger Brawl-Stars-Klon,
der nach nur einer Stunde vollständig
entwickelt wurde. Und es hat all dies
in reinem Code mit Three.js erstellt.
Schauen Sie sich nur die Qualität
dieses Spiels an, das das neue Fable
5.2 generiert hat. Dies sieht wirklich
nach einem ziemlich ausgereiften Spiel
aus, für das ein Entwickler
wahrscheinlich mehrere Wochen gebraucht
hätte, um es vollständig zu
programmieren. Mit Animationen und
verschiedenen Texturen, alles wurde
vollständig von Fable 5.2 generiert.
Ich kann einfach nicht glauben, dass
dieses Modell eine solche Qualität
ausgeben konnte. Schauen wir nach vorne
: Wir wissen, dass Gemini 4 angeblich
in der Arena getestet wird, und bisher
schlägt es sich in fast jedem Bereich
beachtlich gut. Derselbe Prompt wurde
mit GBC-6 Astra ausgeführt, und im
direkten Vergleich wirkt die Version
von Gemini 4 unglaublich stark; man
kann wirklich sagen, dass es absolut
mit den modernsten Modellen
vergleichbar ist. Aber heute haben wir
auch die Gemini 4-Benchmarks gesehen,
die angeblichen Benchmarks, die
überall auf X kursierten. Doch Leute,
das ist eine Fälschung. Das ist ein
komplettes Bild, das von einer KI
generiert wurde. Tut mir leid, euch da
enttäuschen zu müssen, aber wir haben
viele neue, beeindruckende Vergleiche
für euch. Dies ist ein Test, bei dem
Gemini 4 gegen Fable 5 und GBZ 6 Astra
antrat. Gemini 4 Pro konnte bei dieser
spezifischen Generierung unglaublich
detaillierte Strukturen erzeugen, und
man sieht einfach, dass es ein extrem
ausgefeiltes Endergebnis liefert, das
vielleicht sogar besser aussieht als
das der beiden anderen Modelle. Wenn
euch dieses Video gefällt und ihr den
Kanal unterstützen möchtet, könnt
ihr eine Spende über die „Super
Thanks“-Option unter dem Video in
Betracht ziehen. Oder ihr könnt
unserem privaten Discord beitreten, wo
ihr monatlich kostenlosen Zugang zu
mehreren Abonnements verschiedener
KI-Tools sowie tägliche KI-News,
exklusive Inhalte und vieles mehr
erhaltet. Als Nächstes folgt eine
ziemlich interessante Geschichte, laut
dem Wall Street Journal. Googles Gemini
hat angeblich während eines
Cybersicherheitstests auf das offene
Internet zugegriffen und ist in die
Systeme von drei echten Unternehmen
eingedrungen. Dies wird als der erste
bekannte Ausbruch eines
Google-KI-Modells beschrieben. Google
ist mit diesem neuen Modell also
definitiv auf einem guten Weg. Google
erklärte jedoch, dass das Modell jeden
Eindringversuch stoppte, sobald es
erkannte, dass es auf ein echtes
Unternehmen zugegriffen hatte, und gab
an, dass der Vorfall keinen Schaden
verursacht habe. Google teilte
außerdem mit, dass der Vorfall zum
damaligen Zeitpunkt keine umfassendere
öffentliche Bekanntmachung erforderte.
Das ist eine wirklich coole und
interessante Geschichte von Google,
besonders da ihre Modelle bisher eher
unter den Erwartungen geblieben sind.
Dies deutet wirklich darauf hin, dass
ihre neuen Modelle in Bezug auf ihre
Fähigkeiten in verschiedenen Bereichen
ziemlich kompetent sind. Als Nächstes:
XAI hat Grok 4.7 heute doch nicht
veröffentlicht, da es so aussieht, als
sei es auf nächste Woche verschoben
worden. Aber sie haben Grok Voice
Transcribe 2.0 angekündigt. Dies ist
ein mehrsprachiges
Spracherkennungsmodell, das laut
Artificial Analysis derzeit bei der
Genauigkeit von 32
Streaming-Transkriptionsmodellen auf
Platz eins liegt. Es unterstützt
außerdem sowohl Batch-als auch
Echtzeit-Streaming sowie Funktionen wie
Sprecher-Diarisierung,
Mehrkanal-Transkription, 18-Biasing,
automatische Formatierung, das
Entfernen von Füllwörtern und
intelligente Spracherkennung. XCI
entwickelt Grok also eindeutig über
ein reines Sprachmodell hinaus weiter
in Richtung Echtzeit-Sprach-und
Audio-KI. Als Nächstes gibt es ein
ziemlich großes Update für Claude
Code, das gerade Unterstützung für
agents.md hinzugefügt hat. Ab dieser
neueren Version 2.1.277 prüft Claude
Code automatisch auf agents.md und
verwendet diese Datei, falls keine
Claude.md im Ordner gefunden wird;
dieses Verhalten lässt sich über den
Befehl/config steuern. Das wirklich
Interessante daran ist, dass dies auf
Claude Code Mods und einem kommenden
System basiert, mit dem Entwickler die
Claude-Code-Umgebung anpassen und sogar
ihre eigenen Produktanweisungen
erstellen können. Claude Code wird
durch dieses neue Feature also in
Zukunft deutlich flexibler anpassbar
sein. Kommen wir zu KI-Leaks: Es wurden
Gemini Worlds gezeigt–eine
beeindruckende frühe Demo, die ein
unglaublich detailliertes, immersives
Umgebungssystem präsentiert, in dem
man verschiedene Welten erkunden kann.
Google verfolgt hier einen spannenden
Ansatz, denn ich bin überzeugt, dass
dies eine großartige interaktive
Methode zum Lernen und zur
Präsentation verschiedener
Visualisierungen ist. Die Idee ist,
dass man sich durch KI-generierte
Welten bewegen und sie aus
verschiedenen Perspektiven erkunden
kann–egal ob mikroskopisch klein,
völlig imaginär oder tief im Weltraum
. Google investiert bereits stark in
diese Richtung mit Genie 3 und Project
Genie, das interaktive Umgebungen in
Echtzeit während der Navigation
generiert. Sollte diese
Gemini-Worlds-Demo authentisch sein,
sieht es so aus, als könnte Google
dieses Konzept noch weiter vorantreiben
. Jede hier gezeigte Umgebung sieht
unglaublich detailliert aus, und ich
bin sehr gespannt, wann sie dies
tatsächlich veröffentlichen werden.
Zuletzt gibt es ein Update von Figure:
Sie haben nun Helix 2.5 vollständig
eingeführt, und das ist wirklich
beeindruckend. Ich möchte diesen
humanoiden Roboter unbedingt kaufen und
bei mir zu Hause haben, da er die Art
und Weise, wie Roboter unser Leben
unterstützen–etwa beim Wäschefalten
oder in der Küche–, revolutionieren
wird. Es gibt nun Aufnahmen von vier
Stunden, in denen Helix 2.5 in 30
verschiedenen Haushalten ohne
zusätzliches Training arbeitet. Dabei
wurden zufällig ausgewählte Roboter
aus dem Standby-Modus in unbekannte
Umgebungen geschickt, in denen sie
zuvor noch nie waren. Und hier ist es
in der Lage, tatsächlich in völlig
unterschiedlichen realen Umgebungen zu
arbeiten, ohne für jedes Zuhause neu
trainiert werden zu müssen. Dies ist
ein weiterer großer Einblick in die
Richtung, in die sich
Allzweck-Humanoide schon bald
entwickeln werden. Aber Leute, das war
es auch schon mit dem heutigen Video.
Ich werde alle Links, die ich im
heutigen Video verwendet habe, unten in
die Beschreibung setzen. Schaut euch
unbedingt den World of AI Insider Club
an, das ist unsere Schul-Community.
Werft einen Blick auf die World of AI
Bob Kading Plattform und das Benchmark,
um bessere Einblicke zu erhalten,
welches Modell ihr verwenden solltet.
Schaut euch den zweiten Kanal an.
Meldet euch unbedingt für unseren
Newsletter an. Kommt zu uns auf Discord
. Folgt mir auf Twitter. Und zu guter
Letzt: Abonniert den Kanal. Aktiviert
die Benachrichtigungsglocke. Gebt
diesem Video ein Like. Und bitte seht
euch unsere früheren Videos an, damit
ihr bei den neuesten KI-Nachrichten auf
dem Laufenden bleibt. Aber mit diesem
Gedanken, Leute, habt einen
großartigen Tag. Verbreitet
Positivität. Und wir sehen uns schon
bald wieder. Macht's gut, Leute.